there's nothing cooler than an anime
powerup specifically there's nothing
more exciting than watching your
favorite character getting the crap
kicked out of them only for them to
power up at the last second and defeat
their opponent
[Music]
[Applause]
but those kinds of power-ups don't only
happen in anime eSports is no stranger
to players having sudden burst of skill
out of nowhere we've seen the pros make
impossible comebacks unleash devastating
hidden techniques and even go super
saiyan right before our very eyes here
are the top 10 anime power-ups in
esports kicking off our list at number
10 is a historic performance from
skadoodle at the boston major in 2018
heading into the major skadoodle was on
his last legs as a pro he had been
underperforming for a long time and it
felt like he was just days from getting
kicked absolute slaughter house and
cloud miner on the receiving end of it
gonna get in there get it done get the
paint over with four hours what about
you getting tries to read himself but I
love my sit once in on the action it
looks like a deflated team hit for cloud
nine that was until Boston out of
nowhere skadoodle went super saiyan
putting c9 on his back and taking them
straight to victory
[Applause]
skunk glue making that catch baby and
much like Goku after winning the MVP
title for his heroic performance scar
retired but maybe one day and they will
need to call on their champion once
again to save the day
[Music]
every anime hero needs a signature move
think Goku's kamehameha or Naruto's
Rasengan or ignores fervor of battle
Leona to support champion Leona's makes
so much sense
going into world's 2017 quarterfinals
and when the misfits we're gonna do any
real damage against defending world
champions SKT but ignore had been
practicing with a secret weapon worlds
was all about ardent censor that year
which made games extremely defensive and
slow but ignored decided to say screw
the rules and play aggro on a support
champion going hard on SK T's bot lane
watch the glare
[Applause]
[ __ ] pull the trigger everyone always
here comes max floor two to get a piece
of the party he
shield and now the assists are going
across the map misfits may have lost the
series but they took SKT to a full five
game proving that their unique strategy
was enough to take on the best players
in the world
I mean who accounts for an eighth stack
fervor Leona in a hit a level one all
enemy it's insane coming in at number
eight is a truly animus ly inconsistent
player and because some of the best
teams in the world were on his path of
the grand finals is a Shanghai major he
needed to find some consistency if he
wanted to win so he removed his training
wits and busted out the ultimate glass
cannon the ember spirit double rapier
gosh could I know Morioka sister to
karate
god I know it's not easy take it back
see see that's our context a cashier
best boss CPD as well
[Applause]
Julie DG with TVs Arabia and it's
changing they were all gonna miss off
mine
that's the man that just lost three
writers in the end this secret jutsu was
the key to ee sama destroying his
opponents and picking up his first major
win in one of the most dominant fashions
we've seen in the grand finals taking
the number seven spot on our list is a
powerup that smash fans know all too
well
losers bracket mango mango is one of the
greatest smashers of all time but when
it gets pushed to his limits in the
loser's bracket mango shows off his true
powers got a present for you
mango dropped into losers at the
beginning of top eight at the big house
nine and then he tore through every
opponent with no mercy kind of a weird
way that made it awkward to smash the
eye he was cooking but when you miss
something like that it just changes the
cards it changes the flow of the game
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
he's alive I cannot believe i saw a
yoshi stories blast loads grew an extra
couple meters when he knows he can't
shine a shield not a big deal
i'll roll take a page out of Johnnie
Kim's book loser's bracket mango is
melees ultimate power because when the
goat is cornered he's unbeatable maybe
wait for a wave goes back into that and
manga with all the save
[Applause]
Daigo is the final boss of Street
Fighter which is why Tokyo wanted to
challenge him to a first attend to prove
he was the best in the world
unfortunately for Tokyo Daioh has a
secret powerup that takes weeks to reach
prep time Daigo when I go has time to
prepare for his opponent he's nearly
unbeatable like all great anime villains
die go strategize and planned exactly
how to crush our upstart hero
[Music]
but unfortunately for Daigo the hero
always finds a way to beat the villains
final form with a powerup of their own
takedo won the rematch but now it's
Dido's turn to seek revenge at the
halfway point on our list is the king of
the jungle
bengi who came alive at the last
possible moment to defend his crown they
would have had to be playing a lot of or
some scrims with bengi on Nidalee to try
and train this up to a point where
they're confident first picking it in
what could be an elimination game bengi
was always a great jungler but by 2016
fans have begun to wonder if his time
had come and gone he spent most of the
season on the bench as other junglers
surpassed him you know how his Benke
been able to train his Nidalee he didn't
play it during the regular season he's
not known as a newbie player but in Game
four of the world semi-finals SKT
brought out bengi as a last-ditch effort
to stave off the elimination with only
one chance and defend his honor
bengi unlocked his eight gates and got
to work either with a sword soloing
and now it could be dangerous Wolf's
gonna die in a couple more shots anyway
thanks again anyway goodbye
got hit a return and now the double-bond
forces of flat sub curl this tide of a
baker not a matter if you already have
the playing a champion he'd never played
professionally bengi crushed the
competition proving once and for all
that he is truly the jungle personified
escaped he believed so much in their God
and Savior bengi that they're 80 carry
is willing to flash in just to heal him
taking the number-4 spot on our list is
a Drent who under the tutelage of his
wise old master zeus unlocked sage mode
at the 2017 krakow major again he had
your analyzed up in the playoffs who
said he was slow in the start of this
game he was first map he was nowhere to
be seen but then he immediately shows up
on this map hobbit and him I think
combined had over 50 kills gambit were
by no means the favorite coming into the
major but the team's wise and
battle-hardened igl zeus believed that
he could win it all
unfortunately zeus was getting older and
he just couldn't frag like he used to
enter a dren his pupil zeus passed on
his knowledge and adrenalin ready to
destroy his opponents with the garden
hose could call him hozier weeding out
these of these plants of Australis and a
trend finishing things off a brief round
if they're gonna read ragu anyone going
down they should be fine
to Smaug the dragon he goes out
perfectly no smoke required
he's already got the first dress
through the smoke comment does the
damage and he's gonna try and plant as
fast as he can eight seconds even
bothered shots them down and damn it
reset your models immediately in the end
gambit means the best teams in the world
to win the major and it was all things
to add Ren and his wise masters
teachings taking the number three spot
on our list is the ultimate comeback
player the man who always powers up at
the last second
m'kay layout to be your 2019 Evo
champion you get up from it but in the
end and trail will arrive a grand final
in smash ultimate there is no name more
synonymous with dominance than MKA oh
and that's because the moment it looks
like he's about to lose is the moment
when Alejo transforms game for Alejo the
layout that emerges when he's fighting
off the elimination is more powerful
than ultra instinct Sharingan or bankai
in this state leo is nearly unbeatable
game court by the waifus r4m title I say
it but I mean it's it's a truth I like
that you didn't go for the best attack
immediately because it's not and zero
but that's gonna be the stop you charged
it to just in case he knew it was gonna
be alright and I'd love to mr. Brender
fight well we saw a lot of times he just
stayed there on the ground wait to see
what tweaks gonna do Zika the double
jump is he gonna like trip to a sage or
not he's straight-up just met him at the
air and say you know I'm gonna get
aggressive right here I need this board
game game for Alejo has destroyed many
opponents but none got hit harder than
tweak who is about to win Evo
when game for Alejo showed up and took
it all away one more stock to win Evo
can he do it or will AO seal the deal
here
coming alive right now 74% in for little
Sporto cannot handle through much market
agonizing for off the redline doesn't
even gay 49% only taking the runner-up
spot on our list is the moment that
scarlet rose up to challenge Korea's
best in 2013 scarlet was making a name
for herself as a top Western player but
of course this was Starcraft 2 where
even the best Western players hailed
against the might of Korea I've ever
seen more exciting conclusion on that
kind of a scale to a Starcraft game if
that was on unbelievable
scarlet faced down a group of Korean
Titans at Red Bull battlegrounds 2013
and had to face her most dangerous foe
to date bomber but scarlet put her
secret training to work and shocked her
enemy with a dangerous technique this is
a mouthy really close Marcus
burrow is done that means burrowed
banelings this could be a bomber can't
afford to scan so the spurt oh the
brittle they're huge they're just over
to the right a little bit more bring
them out Batum is trying to beat
that kind of thing happens chases event
that's back in there's some banelings
here to reinforce as well but that was
what I gave you what a game
scarlet refuses to engage without the
noodle list the Queen's taking damage a
queen falls but scarlet on the regroup
is
[Applause]
and just like that
scarlet stunned the Starcraft world
I don't have anything else to say we've
got some I'm just gonna sit here and be
in awe a little bit the number one spot
on our list goes to the player who
spends the entire year in a training arc
all for one tournament Anna is one of
the most mysterious players in eSports
he has an innate talent for dota and
he's one of the best players in the
world but then suddenly he disappears
does he go off to train under waterfalls
is he unlocking the secrets of the
universe is he putting his skills in the
hyperbolic time chamber no one knows
thanks for waiting guys did you miss
anything
it's good to have you back all we can
say for sure is that whenever he emerges
from his mysterious slumber Ana always
shows up even stronger than before
cheering - trolley smell the back line
this noble bkb mr. Burroughs
on to aggressive once eco goes down as
are up to stamp positive you the damage
winters first full team in place will
become a new of the buybacks coming in
the undines gonna try and help him out
but I'm talkin have the man he's already
dead Anna it's just too big and he still
has full HP as well babaca he's gonna
die the illusions here Diana thinks
about it he knows how strong he is he
could feel keep on going
in fact he's gonna triangle and help out
Gerak's again aggressive good play by
Cherry's duty once a behaves on cue he's
like manna he's just gonna keep on
rampaging through all of these heroes
truly he's achieved the most powerful
anime powerup in all of eSports alright
folks that's our list if you think we
missed a player that should have been on
here then hit us up in the comments
maybe let us know what your favorite
anime is make sure to sub to the channel
if you haven't done it already and oh
actually we just had an anime powerup of
our own we've unlocked livestream mode
so head on over to twitch.tv slash the
score esports and give us a follow so
you never miss a stream thanks for
watching and see you next week you know
what's [ __ ] up so boruto is Naruto son
which is a stupid name like a really
stupid name obviously but I think he's
called that because it's like the way
that you would say bolt in Japanese like
Bo do talk bolt but that implies that
Naruto's name is NART and NART is not a
great name for your hero like the arts a
bad name it means nothing it just kind
of sounds like nerds there's also I
think like Sasuke's kid is called sada
which is salad so his daughter's name is
it's a Bolton salad or Borton salad
really